well if you've ever wanted to own a  piece of movie history you have another  chance  thousands of memorabilia items will be  auctioned off in june at the prop store  down in southern california  they include things like harry potter's  wand and glasses  darth vader's helmet and the most sought  after item worn by an iconic character  one of the hottest items in our auction  is this original  indiana jones harrison ford fedora hat  from indiana jones in the temple of doom  the second film  this is valued in auction for 250 to  350 000 300  000. well you can bid from anywhere in  the world including here in vegas  the prop store says there is memorabilia  for all budgets